tutti ragazzi per questo voglio sono
famigerati saltati su geometri dash
inizia a scaldarsi col primo livello a
caso che si chiama altair l'ho voluto
fare dovuto fare perché credo di poterlo
finire siamo abituati ad esso giocare
solo livelli della madonna cosa è
successo se tu fare quando saltare nel
cerchio bene credo credo credo di non
poterlo fare tutto non so che dire
quando gioca sta roba ragazzi ogni volta
mi sento sempre più professional e
sempre senza e sempre con meno patata
cioè un'escalation di gnocca il
contrario nel senso che me ne arriva
sempre meno ogni volta che faccio video
su geometri nasce ci sarà un motivo
però vabbè ma la prima nazione da restar
balletto farla bene ok no mio dio no 15
per cento ragazzo livello impossibile
superski parlo ma voglio provendono
l'ultima volta
un'ultima proprio lui va bene sono
contento prossimo livello o almeno hanno
messo una canzone non copi ha aiutato
almeno questo c'è di buono questo possa
monetizzare ancora ok ok no
e sono stupido ma perché io io io io
sono per cento senso quando io vedo due
p2 sulla lavagna vado in crisi quindi
figura di giocare a geometri da sci in
questi casi sarà che ospita mi sono
svegliato male stamattina non lo so sarà
che mi reputo troppo intelligente sarà
che forse pietro doveva essere aiuto per
colpisca in italia invece di subito io
per qualche strano motivo o me li merito
non me li merito perché non sono capaci
a fare le cose basilari tipo vedere che
c'è un ostacolo e non andare sullo
stacco lo porco demonio allora giampiero
che stiamo notando questo video famiglia
ed era un attimo come sei contento di
tagliare tutte queste volte che muoio
grazie già penso che sei sempre così
gentile ti voglio bene tutti lo dedico
questo ma che bravo para che non ci
faccio più fare tagli guarda è bravo non
sta ritagliando niente vero mamma mia
proprio lui proprio lui proprio lui è
diventato free bird 8 mamma mia che ho
fatto una provata arriva il drop club
non fate commenti per core per favore ve
lo chiedo per cortesia
allora ragazzi il discorso è che io in
ogni video di geometria dash che faccio
voglio vedere che voglio far vedere che
finisco almeno un livello ciò questa
fissa in testa c'è chi non lo fa
ma io voglio farlo perché secondo me
finire almeno un livello a video porco
demonio e chi mi ha fatto finire un
livello a video
secondo me è doveroso per chi guarda
mille di geometria nas quindi vedrete
sempre un livello finito si spera almeno
[Musica]
ma che non è facile sembra una cagata
altro gioco ma vi assicuro che non lo è
let's golf
[Musica]
bene e ancora non capitolo distanza di
anni tutte ste cagate che mi danno alla
fine dei livelli a che cosa servono ma
l'importante finirli quindi va bene è il
via il livello di oggi abbiamo finito
almeno quello flap in che senso propri
bird ma cosa stai dicendo
come com'è possibile lara gut ermi come
hanno fatto propri birds non sto male
hanno fatto propri vertici
bellissimo ma non è vero ma quanto fatto
bene è dato sapere fissi ma si sa come
va ecco porca vacca hanno fatto troppi
bard uguale ma cavolo ma non sa come si
vede se lo fa ste cose giuro dall
incredible da la precisione porca vacca
quanto è difficile questo gioco ragazzi
e sono ancora bravino il gioco era
diventato leggendario me lo ricordo
[Musica]
attenzione attenzione ecco non così
rallentato ciao ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta
pace fatta mamma mia sono caricati in
mano una certa veramente creato in mano
va bene
bellissimo con più veramente non ci
avrei dato un euro complimenti geometri
calf la p perde crystal che in questa
che è fatta lo stesso creatore può
essere che è bello stare di lato
comandando questo quadrato e poi chi se
lo piglia
se non vinco ti ammazzo la famiglia però
non son riuscito me lo ricordo era una
cantilena che cantavo sempre quando lo
facciamo già sta canzoncina i tempi ero
diventato conosciuto per questa cosa
ragazzi porca vacca ce l'ho fatta e
vabbè allora come facciamo come faccio
non lo so il livello a memoria spiega mi
devo fare la mia vita spiega mi non puoi
mettermi delle cose che non conosco
porca vacca
[Musica]
ecco questo ho dovuto tirare indovinare
e ho fatto bene
dopo mi ha proprio lui
raga con chi sono diventato veramente
non è vero ma quasi
almeno decente non è vero neanche quello
faccio vomitare mi piace che geometri da
sci nel tempo non si sa mai morto perché
è un gioco che da un sacco di gli spunti
e sarà fa quando smetterà mai tu
e veramente figo cioè se continuano a
fare flachi per qualcuno può fare un
livello con la mia faccia per favore
detto ciò che siamo sul finale perfetto
complimenti
[Musica]
allora allora allora piano bravissimo
bravissimo onore con attenzione a te
nessuno di gesù fa delle somme e parigi
parigi e vince ma mai amo sono a tema
sfondo i colori visto livello comunque
fantastico coltiva vincere stelline
l'ignaro di che cosa servano ma va bene
se volete stelline chiedete a me ma
andiamo su switch
ecco aiuto mannaia o cui oggi noi già
finiti tra i livelli non è male come
inizio
[Musica]
non sto capendo ma va bene non ho capito
niente di quello che è successo ma ok
ragazzi un solo tentativo perso livello
dove arrivo arrivo così ci vuoi provare
non la sento un solo tentativo ragazzi
no porco demonio ma che facciano due ok
quando saltiamo perfetto ragazzi questa
è quella buona
questa è quella buona lo vinco in una in
una proprio la sento guardalo li cielo o
ragazzi celo celo fermi cielo credetemi
gli regalo un sogno to day to day fa vj
cosa che sto dicendo ste cagate occhio
[Musica]
o c'è rischio di morire tantissimo ho
vinto ce l'ho fatta veramente più senza
c'era un primo tentativo una spiaggia
thank you so much mair bynight freddy's
cosa c'entra spiegami però fammi vedere
per curiosità se non è epico me ne vado
ma io sono fi ne de pedis 4
[Musica]
ragazzi
ok io non so che non sapevo che
geometrica potesse essere quasi
artistico complimenti bravissimo che mi
piace il fatto che tu voglia essere così
competitivo bello sempre e comunque
meglio di quelli con lembo aree per
carità di dio
spero che questo video di giorni fidarci
vi sia piaciuto
vado a scalare le vette più alte del
mondo mettete mi piace al video
schiaffetto iscriviti e la campanella
per rimanere aggiornati sulle nuove
uscite nel canale stranamente secondo
canale
[Musica]